Tell me something
you can go anywhere you want right
any timeline and the universe
Why do you want to stay and fight to save this one
you changed the future
and you changed the past
are you in
Hooooly
Welcome back everyone this will be my flash movie
trailer video there's a whole bunch of footage in
easter eggs obviously michael keaton's batman
is the big star that's like the big wtf moment
but there's a whole bunch of other stuff going on
in this including a flash from another universe
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a bunch more trailers from dc
fandom that i'm still working through so i'll be
posting those in the next couple of days but
just starting at the beginning of the trailer
and working our way through shot by shot so the
whole idea here is that michael keaton's batman
the older version of batman 60 something batman
batman beyond however you want to think about him
is narrating the entire trailer and basically
explaining the flash point of it all about how
the flash can go anywhere on the multiverse that
he wants about how he changed the past and he
changed the future and asking him why he wants to
save this one timeline so bad and then focusing so
much on the actual flashpoint of it all with his
mother dying but the big twist is that there are
two versions of the ezra miller flash one from
an alternate universe and obviously we have the
brand new super girl in here too and with the
exception of him going back to his childhood
home to see his mother before she was killed all
the footage is happening in the alternate earth
that michael keaton's batman comes from where
the tim burton movies took place batman and
batman returns so val kilmer's batman and george
clooney's batman are both now on separate earths
and other universes but the actual footage starts
with both the different flashes from different
universes pulling up to his version of wayne
manor and they're trying to make this look almost
exactly the way that it looked during batman 1989
and batman returns his version of wayne manor
i love the way they mirror some of their actions
too they both climb out of the cab at the same
time and obviously it's a late model car so that
you know that they haven't gone back in time to
visit him they're visiting him in present day
our version of ezra miller from the main justice
league earth from the justice league snyder cut
is the one in the brown jacket with the short hair
the version of the flash from the alternate
universe the other barry allen is the one in the
yellow jacket with the long hair that's how you
can tell the difference between the two also the
difference in their flash costumes which i'll talk
about in a second too because i know one of them
looks really sus then you see the camera slowly
panned through the interior of the entryway of
his wayne manor it almost looks empty everything's
covered up the whole idea is that alfred died a
long time ago because this is a much older version
of batman like i said batman beyond would be a
good comparison to make then our version of barry
allen from the main justice league earth like i
said brown jacket is the one to turn the lights on
inside michael keaton's bat cave and you can kind
of see the cobwebs on it like it hasn't been used
in a long time or at least has fallen a little
into disrepair even if batman is still acting as
batman in some capacity when they go to visit him
if you've ever seen batman beyond batman continues
to be batman until his body is just literally
broken down to the point where he can barely
walk without a harness they kind of got into
that a little bit during the dark night rises with
the younger version of christian bale's batman who
had got a little bit older but the wear and tear
on his body had been so bad that he really did
have trouble getting around then this is the main
version of the flash in his brand new multiverse
costume that ben affleck's batman is going to
be making for him he also has a version of the
comic book gold boots now they're highly stylized
gold boots but this was another big thing with the
flash tv show talking about grant gustin's
flash i know everyone's hoping for a cameo
they just gave grant gustin the gold boots from
the comics too so they're just trying to be a
little bit more comic book accurate but the way
they're playing this footage they're implying that
this is happening on his earth he's going back
in time to visit his mother before she was killed
like this is meant to be his childhood
home that you later see him walking into
in broad daylight now the flash movie is only
adapting some aspects of the flashpoint storyline
instead of using the reverse flash like you
would normally expect them to do in a flashpoint
storyline because reverse flash is the person who
killed barry's mother there's a really important
reason why they're using this alternate universe
berry which i'll talk about in a second when we
see his new costume the alternate barry's new
costume and obviously when he's touching his
mother here you have michael keaton's voice over
talking about why are you fighting so hard to save
this particular timeline this particular earth
it's all about the flash learning to move
past the death of his mother to make peace with it
and just getting stuck on it before that happens
and because of that causing a whole bunch
of problems so then when michael keaton's
batman says you change the future you change
the past and he's touching this hand here
remember which berry is the alternate berry which
barry is our version of berry so the alternate
berry is the one in yellow so it's alternate barry
reaching out and touching someone's hand who looks
like they're either knocked out or unconscious
this could be michael keaton's batman it could
be our main version of ezra miller's flash then
even though they're kind of trying to give you an
anxiety attack with this music and you see this
bloody batman cowl on the floor in a bathroom
in batman's suit behind a michael keaton's
batman suit behind it i think this is meant to
be completely separate footage and it just meant
to show you batman after one of his adventures
and you see some of the wounds on his body in a
way that you didn't during the original michael
keaton batman movies then this is our main version
of the flash in his brand new multiverse costume
with the cowl up but he's inside michael keaton's
bat cave looking at one of his suits like he's
gone into his armory where he keeps his suits
and he's looking at one of the batman suits
this might be after he first comes to this version
of earth and doesn't completely realize where he's
come to like wait a minute this isn't my batman's
bat cave so he probably sees this batman suit and
notices the symbol is different the suit looks
different like wait a minute where am i who's this
batman now this is the alternate universe version
of the flash with the new version of super girl
and if you couldn't tell they're inside michael
keaton's wayne manor but if you haven't seen her
costume this is what it looks like her superman
symbol looks exactly like henry cavill's superman
symbol but i believe the way they're explaining
her is that she's on the justice league of another
universe so i believe she's not meant to be from
the main justice league earth i don't know if
she's like a replacement for superman that came
to earth in michael keaton's batman earth like
if there's no superman in michael keaton's batman
earth but there was a supergirl or if she's from
a completely different universe but one of the
rumors for the movie is that we're going to see
an alternate universe roster of the justice league
and she just happens to be on that team then
when i was talking about the alternate universe
version of the flash's costume being kind of sus
this is him basically spray painting flash logos
onto an old version of michael keaton batman armor
they're in michael keaton's batcave when this
is happening you can see the bat computer the
bank of monitors behind him here maybe he's from
the same earth as michael keaton's batman maybe
he's the flash of this earth or maybe he's from
a completely different universe either way it
seems like he does not have his own flash costume
before the beginning of the film but you actually
see him in his full costume after he's repainted
the batman armor standing behind the main version
of the flash our version of flash from the main
justice league earth so a lot of people saw his
homemade batman flash combo costume here and
they're like wait a minute is this red death
because red death is like a dragon ball gogeta
fusion speedster of batman and the flash combined
that's not what they're doing with this he's not
meant to be a version of red death or anything
like that it's just a homemade suit in their
repurposing old batman armor but here's the thing
there's a rumor that he is actually going to be
the secret villain of the film and going to be
a dark version of the flash and they're using the
flashpoint storyline to tell that then there's a
separate scene of our main version of the flash
showing the alternate universe barry because
remember alternate universe barry is wearing the
yellow jacket his version of a flash ring from the
comics so because ben affleck's batman is the one
that gives him this brand new multiverse upgraded
flash suit i'm also assuming that he's the one
that creates the flash ring so they will have
his new suit come out of the flash ring just like
it does in the comics then we finally see michael
keaton's batman walk out in his bat suit and we've
already seen a version of what the suit's going
to look like in the movie and it's just like his
original suits from batman 1989 and batman returns
the only minor difference between the suits in
those two movies is that the batman return suit
was just a much more armored up version that
he used because of what the catwoman was doing
with her claws then the main version of barry
allen flash with supergirl in her costume and
the alternate universe flash in the batman version
of the flash costume all standing in front of the
back computer looking at him asking him are you in
because when michael keaton's batman is asking him
why do you want to fix this particular timeline
why do you want to stay here so badly he's talking
both about barry allen's mother dying and him
wanting to save her on his original earth but
they're also talking about saving michael keaton's
earth too but clearly something goes wrong on
michael keaton's earth because of what they're
doing with flashpoint one of these versions of
the flash either our main barry allen or the
alternate universe berry changes the past and
something goes completely wrong then the alternate
universe version of barry remember the long hair
whips the cover off of michael keaton's batmobile
so the bringing back the original batmobile
but the difference is now is that it's actually
a four-seater instead of just a two-seater and
they just made it extra big so you can have both
versions of the flash riding around in it with
michael keaton's batman instead of just one of
the flashes but when i was talking about this dark
version of the flash this alternate universe berry
being kind of like the secret villain of the film
i think the way they're playing it instead of
just going for legit reverse flash unless they're
really trying to trick us with this is they're
using the whole lesson of flashpoint like barry
just learning to deal with his mother's death
and moving past it in the alternate universe
version of flash is just someone who does not
learn that lesson refuses to move on from it
and it just drives him to a very dark place and
if we're talking about flashes from alternate
universes people asking is grant gustin going
to have a cameo scene in this i'm hoping that
he has a small cameo just so they can pay off the
crisis on infinite earth's crossover scene with
ezra miller's flash and i'm also really hoping for
a small cameo scene or some small role for john
wesley's ship's version of the flash his original
barry allen from the tv series that died during
crisis on infinite earths or a version of jay
garrick anything at all it would be a crime to not
include him in this movie in some way so if you
spotted any easter eggs in this that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in the
comments i've got another brand new batman trailer
video that i'm posting with a bunch of different
footage that they didn't put in the actual trailer
so that'll be my next video then i'll do videos
for the other trailers and teasers that they drop
there's a shazam 2 trailer and then there's also
a peacemaker trailer that i'll be doing make sure
you have alert sample for my channel so you don't
miss any of that everyone click here for my batman
trailer video and easter eggs and click here for
my brand new black adam trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!